which is also why I think Sarah touched on this too, right?
The digital activation goes so far.
We just take those those experiences that we build up for you guys and then those live on your socials.
Those can get funneled into your meta ads and your Google ads.
So that way when people go on Facebook or Instagram, higher doses popping up everywhere and it's directing them right to those virtual experiences where you know they can shop directly from those experiences.
So we're driving revenue from there.
we're able to educate folks because people are curious, right?
If they're on higher dose for the first time, they're like, oh, what the heck is this product?
What's it going to do for me?
Even just being able to educate someone immediately from that ad will lead into revenue being driven, right?
So activating from a digital standpoint, I'm glad you see the value there because that's where we're going to be the stickiest early on until
We collaborate together because again, we've been in this space for a while.
We like to think that we're the experts here.
So when it comes to putting QR codes on packaging and getting a call to action in place, like what's going to drive somebody to scan a QR code, right?
What's going to get them to register?
But
That's when the collaboration comes into play and allowing us to kind of steer the ship on like, Hey, this is how we're going to drive the most conversions and the most scans for you guys once those QR codes, you know, really hit the wild right or the packaging has to change or whatever that may be so.
Does that kind of resonate or did I kind of just go off?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no
I guess on your pricing model, how does that work?
Are you collecting a percentage of revenue that's driven through those rich experiences?
I haven't dived in deep on the pricing structure, so I'm curious.
Typically, I would demo and then dive into pricing.
I could tell you're a laid back dude.
I'm going to flip-flop it.
I'll do pricing first and then I'll take you through a demo because I'm on a sound no BS.
So I'd rather just kind of give you that first and then we could dive into the demo after.
Um, but we're super transparent when it comes to pricing.
So I'm just going to share the, I'm going to share the deck with you.
So you can see this is what pricing looks like.
So you have our, our standard plan, which is 1300 a month.
Um, and then you have our pro plan, which is $2,000 a month.
The main differentiators between pro and standard with pro, you get meta in Google Analytics integration.
So
what we were talking about on the last call with trauma brands as well as we can take all of the data that we're capturing offline and we're feeding that back into meta in your Google Analytics, which obviously you guys are running 88 ads.
That's a ton of money being spent.
You want to make sure that you're exhausting every additional avenue outside of D to C and funneling that data back into those ads because you want to get the most out of your ad spending.
And then aside from that,
You get a dedicated account manager that's basically handling all the campaigns for you.
Sure.
You guys can build them all out and sure you have a million other things going on.
But we have a customer success team that's handling your account, building up the experiences and really just keeping everything tipped up.
Those are the main differentiators.
But given how many, if you guys weren't spending so much on meta ads and Google Analytics, I would say stick with the standard, but given
the money that you're funneling into those, I would recommend the pro.
But again, these are the two plans that we have.
Now, how that works is there's a two month set up fee.
They're equivalent to that monthly payment.
But because you guys are coming through Sharma, we're going to waive that set up fee.
So there's no set up fee there.
And that's a $4,000 savings.
And then where you will do a 10% discount because you're coming through Sharma as well.
So pay that.
Monthly.
Pro would be basically 1800 a month and then the standard would be 1100 a month.
And then how long does that discount?
Is that like ongoing drop relationship?
Like a forever discount?
Is it like the first month, two months?
How long does that last?
No, no, no, sorry.
So the so it's we signed on a 12 month contract.
So how it would work is it would be a 12 month contract and that 10% discount would live through the entire 12 month cycle.
Right.
Yeah.
So that would be the 1800 for the
for the 12 months, or if you guys wanted to pay for the 12 months upfront, we could figure out something else on top of that to make it a little bit more reasonable for you guys to sign that 12 months upfront.
Yeah, okay.
But it's 12 months regardless, right?
Whether you're doing month-to-month or paying annually, you're in a 12 month contract.
Yeah.
Correct.
Exactly.
But Kate and your CMO are connected, right?
Or their friends are somewhere along those lines?
Possibly.
I don't know.
I don't have to circle back with England.
Yeah.
Okay, I think, yeah, I think Ingrid and Kate are connected.
Again, given it's a, it's a personal relationship there.
If we needed to do like a two month opt out or something, we could, we could work that into into the contract as well, but typically yes, it is a 12 month commitment.
But given there's some ramp outside of digital, we can work some sort of like opt out, you know, to give you guys a little bit more of a safe playing field, implementing something like bridge.
Yeah.
Yeah, given coming from from Sharma that that obviously helps within the personal relationship also we want to make sure that we're getting the best brands on our portfolio and then you know obviously we're trying to help you guys out however we can as well so yeah 10% discount and then the the opt out and we can kind of figure out what that opt out works right if if we need two months three months we can we can figure out the nitty gritty there
Awesome.
I appreciate the transparency, man.
Thanks for diving into that.
Yeah, I just was curious, you know, especially obviously you guys got a very robust platform.
So a lot of people have different models and just curious, but what we jump into the demo got a lot of curiosity there as well.
Yeah, and then out of curiosity too, as far as like the pricing goes, does that kind of align with where you guys are at?
Is that side of the scope would love to hear your transparency there too?
Yeah, so honestly, I'm not too sure on what the budget would be for a tool like this or like what our tool budget is.
I do under like no, our marketing budget.
From what we have allocated towards add dollars, I'd say, you know, 18 for the year might be, well, not bad.
18 hundred a month not bad.
So personally, my personal opinion, I don't feel like that's
out of the expectation I do anticipate tools like this that you're on in that price range.
So, but yeah, ultimately going to come down to Ingrid and I'd imagine if she is connected with, you know, someone on your team, then she's kind of where going into it.
So I don't think there's going to be any sticker shop.
Yeah, and also, and I've been sending these figures after, but one thing to keep in a consideration too is given the like the space that you're in in Durable Goods, we're averaging right now.
around like a 30 to 40% registration rate with the QR codes currently.
And per profile that we're generating, we're averaging about 85 through 100 dollars per profile collected.
So.
see in 30 to 40%.
If we talk extremely conservative figures at a 10% conversion rate, the ROI there, I'm happy to send you over our ROI calculator and you can play with it.
And I'll put in extremely conservative figures, but even at an $18,000 contract, you can easily 10, 20X through return.
Again, extremely, extremely conservative figures, but I can send that over to you so you can show England like, hey, we're paying this much, but these figures are,
You know, way lower than what they're used to seeing, just so you can kind of see the return and obviously build up that use case, right?
That would be awesome.
I appreciate that.
Definitely on the calculate will be good and then even like they're considered to break down.
Um, just so I can communicate that to her.
Do you know, do you know what your AOV is currently?
It's around like $500, like $500 to $600 and that range.
And then I just want to fill it out really quick just so that where I have it on the back end.
And then roughly how many units per order are going, are you guys seeing right now?
Well, that was a great question.
I did have to do that.
What's the easy way for me to let me ask?
Give me one second.
Yeah, yeah, no, no worries.
I would rather you see this now.
So that way, you know, you have all the the towing.
to bring back to Ingrid, but if not, I can send it over you.
I don't want you to harp on this or think that it's crazy, but I can also make a copy of the ROI calculator and send it over to you.
Then you can fill it out.
Yeah, yeah, that might be because it definitely have access to the data to get that.
Don't know the number on hand, but I can when you see if I can.
Yeah, I do.
Quick search.
Yeah.
And then the demo won't take a long.
We can get through it in like 10 minutes.
So don't worry, don't sort it there.
I'm going to send this to your email right now.
I'm going to share access with you so you can see it.
I just sent it over to you, but there's a few things to fill out like AOV units for order, your annual revenue, how many total units you think you're going to sell.
And then of those total units, how many you're anticipating will be offline.
The registration rate, like I said, we average 30 to 40%.
We can leave a conservative figure at like 10% to keep it extremely, extremely low.
Again, that's 20 or 30% lower than what we're typically seeing.
And then estimated revenue per profile were averaging 85 to $100 per profile collected.
If we bump that number down to like
$50 per profile, which is about half of what we're generating right now.
We can play off of those figures.
just so you can see what the ROI looks like that we're driving back D to C or, you know, to the other channels that you're looking for.
But I pretty much like filled in half the information.
I just need the nitty gritty for me.
Cool.
So then diving a little bit, you know, backwards into what we went into the other day as far as, like, these are the experiences that we're going to build up for you guys, right?
And we can build out these experiences specifically to different skis that you guys are selling.
So if you want them for a specific product that you have, there's no limit within that pricing that I sent over to you.
You can build out, you and your team can build out as many as you need to.
And you can run a hundred different campaigns if you really want to.
And then having that account manager on board will be there to facilitate building those out.
But diving a little deeper.
Being integrated with Shopify, we can extract all those assets directly into here.
And then as you're building these out, everything is drag and drop.
So if there are certain things that are interesting to you or you want to build into these workflows, you simply just drag drop and then start creating from there.
Link, for example, if you want a link to a specific page on your website, if you're doing anything influencer or event activation, we can drag and drop anything into these workflows and build them up really however you want.
The call to action right now is registering your product for a warranty.
So right here, we would activate with email and then we're capturing that first party data from there.
But then, as I mentioned the other day, you can shop directly from these experiences,
and then learn a little bit more as well as you kind of go on driving reviews, whatever it may be.
I'll stop here.
Just want to pick your brain on what kind of flows do you think would resonate the most for you guys, right?
Um, obviously shopping experience, the register registration of the product.
Um, I'm not.
I'm sure that would be valuable to us.
Obviously it's valuable.
A lot of other companies.
I would say maybe not so much book or treatment or the brand likes it.
I don't know how diverse the locations or I guess our retail partners are that own like net spotting stuff like that.
For it to like make sense for that call action while I show you.
If that doesn't make sense, pop it out and it's gone forever.
And how it just goes to show how easy it is to build these things up.
But anyway, sorry to cut you off.
Yeah, I'm good.
You're good.
And I mean, there could be like other initiatives like how to use the product.
I know we're just on the team call and some of the FAQ questions that are coming through customer service was kind of like how it turns certain products on.
So there could be, you know, product and use videos, demonstration level videos that will help.
reduce the amount of, like, a strain on customer service by having that information, like, readily available in an experience like this.
And I guess my follow-up question for you is, where do you see brands excelling the most with these placement?
Like, where are they placing these?
bridge experiences within their ecosystem, obviously their socials, their leveraging them and paid media to some extent.
So I'm curious, I guess what placements are you seeing these bridge experiences be most successful?
Yeah, that's a fantastic question.
All of the above is really the best answer wherever you can put a bridge experiences is that is where we're going to be the stickiest.
So obviously starting with socials, Instagram, Facebook, TikTok, if you guys have a page, obviously those are the most trafficked avenues.
everywhere in the world right now.
So taking this link right here, right?
This is the actual like bridge link.
You click that link, it'll take you directly to the bridge experience.
You copy and paste that link, but with the pro plan, what we do is we can change the domain name so it reflects higher dose.
So it's not anything bridge branded.
It's all higher dose branded.
and that would live on your social.
So if you guys have a link tree right now, we can do whatever is in that link tree, we can just build it into the bridge experience flow.
So don't think like, hey, we have a link tree now.
It takes you to all these different places.
Fantastic.
We can build that into the experience while giving you everything else, the shopping, the education, whatever you need them to be.
But to answer your question,
living in your socials, but then also taking it a step further.
Those meta in Google ads, once we're capturing that data, we can build out these bridge experiences to be directly in Facebook or Instagram ads.
So someone sees an ad for higher dose on their Instagram or Facebook and they click on that ad, it'll take them directly to a bridge experience.
And now they're able to shop.
Now they're able to get that education or those points that you were talking to.
Yeah, in your follow up, if you have any, I guess case studies of brands leveraging that, I'd be very curious to see what their experience was, terms of results, because it becomes like another winning page experience of what, then a sense.
So yeah, I would be very curious to see how it plays out.
Because even with warm audiences, people who have bought products, we can push them to register the product and then upsell them to products that we know would be complimentary to what they've already bought.
So we can get that cross-selling, upselling journey started sooner than later through paid ads or through email and allowing people to click these bridge experiences for them to register their product as a follow-up email.
And depending on the product that they bought, the bridge experience will change so that it's aligned with the next consumable upsell.
That product can be featured in this video overlay, like even though they're obviously registered for a different one.
However, maybe there's just a lot of ideas following on how
So we're putting people through a unique experience based on a product that previously bought, allowing them to register, encouraging them to register in a product.
shop for others or learn more about how the users are existing product and all those links are available in one spot.
I think also having that warranty registration goes such a long way because there are a lot of brands out there that we work with that don't necessarily have a powerful call to action and then we have to get extremely creative.
I'm like, okay, how are we going to get someone to scan the QR code?
If I buy
A five hundred dollar product and they're offering a one year warranty why aren't I gonna register for it, right?
So I'm just saying that that goes a long way compared to a lot of other brands that we're working with that don't have much to give away, right?
That's already powerful enough.
Stack that with a few more things.
That's what's really going to drive those registration those registration rates.
So
diving a little bit into the back end of the platform, like the knitting ready.
So you can see what this looks like.
This is again, a campaign that we're running right now.
Feel free to stop me at any point, but happy to dive deeper into any of these like subcategories.
And then if I went over any of this on the last call, feel free to just let me know, but.
Essentially, you're able to track all of this.
You can set start dates and dates track by individual campaigns.
So as you're running different experiences and different geographical locations, you can see, okay, this campaign is working really well in Massachusetts or this one's working really well in California, right?
So tracking those scans and clicks, how many of those are converting into actual registrations,
And then how many times are people clicking through those bridge experiences?
And then again, I think we talked about this quickly on the last call, the revenue attribution.
So indirect revenue, the moment we capture that first party data at any point, the customer makes contact with your product and we capture that data.
If they come back at any point,
and check out with that email or that phone number, we're attributing that to indirect revenue, right?
So it's a way to track it, but not as direct.
But being on Shopify, if someone checks out and makes a purchase of an additional product through that bridge experience, we're attributing that to direct revenue.
So it's coming directly from within a bridge experience, and we're able to track all of that, all right?
Taking it a step further,
registrations.
So people are registering for warranties.
You can see exactly their profiles who they are and get all the information on them.
So where they stand and then kind of the flow that they were taken to until that kind of approval happens and they're registered for your product.
What else we got?
You've seen the most congruency from people that have bought retail and are looking to register their products with bridge experiences, like as far as registration go, or is it do you think the registrations are being driven from like social placements or paid media placements in your personal opinion?
Yeah, I would say the paid media part or like the paid ad part, the reason why it makes so much sense there and why we're seeing so much successes because brands are spending so much money on meta in Google Analytics anyways, and then think of it as like a battery, right?
Your meta ads are like
picture at a full battery of like 100% and right now, if a company's D to C presence is 20%, you're only feeding, met a 20% of that like full capability.
Now, partnered with everything else they were able to do, were able to drive registration, which is customer stickiness, right?
That's good customer retention, that's driving repeat customer.
But you're also taking all of that data that you never had before and funneling into the biggest marketing spend that you guys currently have right now.
living on socials, the product registration, it all pretty much comes full circle.
If that kind of answers your question, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
Cool.
And then diving into like serialized codes.
I don't know.
Did we talk on this last conversation?
I don't think so.
So basically, serialized codes is if you if your products have individual serial numbers on them, which I don't know if they do or if that's something that you plan to roll out with your higher ticketed items, we can tie those directly to a skew.
So you can see who's registering them where they're activating them to just keep a closer look on those individual serial numbers.
This is typically for higher ticketed items like Gosley, the pizza oven that we're working with right now, they sell $2,000 pizza oven, but everything's skewed or everything is serialized.
So it's an easier way to be able to track the interactions between the skews and the serial numbers.
I don't know if you guys are doing this, but it's just an added layer of being able to track where those specific serial numbers are.
Again, don't know if that really resonates with you guys, but figured I'd throw that out there.
And then,
the orders tab.
So this is basically when someone is checking out directly from within a bridge experience, we're able to track those orders and then be exactly where they're coming from, how much these folks are ordering and kind of what their buying patterns are and then feeding all that data back into your email marketing stack as well.
You know, this person bought XYZ at this time, you know, and then build both campaigns from there.
I'll kind of stop there.
That was a lot that I threw at you.
Yeah, we appreciate the context.
Thank you for diving in.
Question following this orders conversation.
Do you guys have integrations with like meta for syncing audiences?
So if I want to pass back some of this order data from bridge specifically, I know I can do that to what clavio as well.
I build an audience segment based off of the tag discount code or other tag things here to get that in the meta, but I'm just curious if you guys have any features directly within bridge.
Yeah, we do.
Yep.
So all of that is attributed directly in so we can we can integrate that all over.
Yeah.
Nice.
Awesome.
Yeah.
Definitely love leveraging this third party data in any way possible.
And yeah, I think that especially in my last screen, we'll look like audiences and quality-seed audiences and we're marketing.
So anybody that bought your bridge experience, you can continue to segment and market to them in different ways.
So all right.
And then I don't know what you guys are doing as far as like influencer activation or event activation, but if you're doing stuff around influencers, once they're advertising the product out to their fan base or whoever it may be,
They simply plug and play that bridge experience as well when they're linking to their customers.
Now folks can purchase directly from there as well.
So that's where the influencer play comes in, right?
And lives experiences like based on their own personal brand, which would be really cool for them too.
Exactly.
We can build all that out.
So it gets extremely customizable, depending on the influencer, depending on the products that you're sending to them and they're advertising to their folks, we build all that out.
So again, that's a quicker way for us to implement the digital side of things before we get the actual QR codes rolled out.
Okay.
Yes.
All right.
I do have a hard stuff at 1230.
Yeah.
Me too.
Cool.
Yeah.
We're both.
All right.
Yeah.
Appreciate it.
I mean, any closing statements you want to make or anything else you want to close along.
Now, I think the only thing is like, I would love to get the ROI or those nitty gritty numbers from you so we can plug into the ROI because that's where you're going to see the real value.
And I have full confidence that if we use extremely low figures compared to our historical data, you're still going to be able to see the returns.
Now, just out of curiosity, one would make sense for us to kind of follow up on this conversation.
I'm going to send you a follow up later today, but
Monday, Monday should be good.
Erid's back today.
I'm actually about to, that's my next call.
It's talking to her, but that should be interesting.
I've timed around Robin with a few other party.
Good stuff.
And follow up with you.
I will I'll throw out something tentative on Monday.
I only have like a few openings.
I'm going to send you out two o'clock Eastern.
If that works, let me know if not my Tuesday is wide open.
So happy to reconvene there too.
Cool.
Sounds good, man.
Appreciate it.
I do.
Thanks so much.
Bye.